hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new let's play afraid of monsters this
is a game made by the same people who
make cry of fear so I have a good
feeling that this is going to be an
excellent and quite terrifying game this
is also going to be the blindest game
I've ever played because I haven't even
seen a screenshot of this game the only
thing I know is that it was their
training room huh it's a different
training room than the half-life
training rumor is it just a bug that's
left over let's see maybe maybe this
training room for being scared by
monsters oh it is ooh
training
all right it's dark ah
go ahead and turn on the light okay sure
that's weird
the way I was doing that Oh
let's see well this definitely this
definitely looks half-life one esque cry
fear was a bit higher quality whoa hello
some doors can are unable to be open
these can be safely ignored this door is
broken and cannot blow well nice
painting hello lady
we got the half-life 1 speed the
environment does not always conform to
what it is perceived to be real
sometimes the impossible is unrestrained
and reality becomes a nightmare ah
oh no what
ah some parts of the environment are
breakable that is what the knife is for
press you use key to pick up the knife
okay don't know why it's doing this ha
ha ha no on fire right right yeah no
foots this is a large fall if you drop
you will die oh ah yeah Pro epic ha Pac
Man ah
sometimes you will pass through areas
such as this straying off the pass will
result in death take your time and go
slow I don't know the meaning of taking
in my time whoa
so quick on the best always this OP
whoops oh yeah what water will break my
fall down I don't know if I trust you ah
oh this water looks good uh yeah at
least is mobile there than they can say
forever jump and then yeah the duck jump
oh my god is dark
Oh can't see anything oh okay okay
use em one needed I don't seem to need
them interesting it is still really dark
oh there if you guys can't see anything
I can't see
ah
now with all your skills combined jump
down and make your way to the exit
defending yourself if necessary use the
bottles of pills regenerate a nihilist
health upon entering this aha I could
read that in my head faster but just
trying to read it loud for you guys okay
so my powers combine oh yeah yeah I'm
out of ammo for the knife ah let my line
suck it can't see so buried line can't
see anything
[ __ ] split the blood oh come on die
till you die ah Oh some light thank you
is it like a set limit on my flashlight
ah now you've got to take for what
afraid of ounces like try the real game
if you're still unsure about how to play
the easy disability is still resetting a
recommended however and feeling
confident try the are difficult lastly
don't forget to search the area I didn't
okay well that was a nice introduction
and I as per my promise for every game
that I will play I'm going to do it on
hard cuz I am a rock alright and here's
the action I don't know why those black
bars are probably trying to make it
widescreen way OA nother Hospital
parkland haha
I know the graphics aren't like they're
pretty dated this is by the same people
that made crime here so I'm going to
imagine to the atmosphere which is a
tutorial
really give me flashbacks a half-life
one
we
we're in a hospital I'm a generic ward
one of the best oh yeah just boss
through the door was they hunger which
is another sort of organ maybe it's not
wasn't all that scary oh we're gonna spy
on some guy in the restroom is that how
we do but it wasn't like unbelievably
scary but it's still great after sure oh
that's me at all okay I'll do that
I really need to take these pills why
why do I need to take those pills
I can't stop taking them
Jerri can't buddy just believe in
yourself
I'm not gonna have to name you - are you
going to name yourself Worthing ham damn
it you can definitely tell the
commodification that they made for crime
fear and how much they push the
half-life planet
look at them shell them down you know
what am i I'm in a toilet or a bathroom
stall
Oh what oh oh these paper clips oh boy
stay on the line ah
oh no it's Holly like mspaint from hell
oh my goodness how did I knew that oh
man I didn't know they could make
animated things on walls in half oh
hello okay if I had any doubt about the
atmosphere for it is gone now Oh
Oh what this outhouse
follow the red ah I'm in a pile of crap
hello the red Oh
follow the red only the red huh
pac-man Oh all those years of training
ah job yeah
epic lead it's quiet very quiet super
quiet can i quick save yes you should
have taken those pills man
Oh God
wear the red go uh uh a few by to follow
that green I know some dastardly demon
would have dammit no oh I'm back here
okay no sir thank you for the offer I'm
okay on my own
shut up
gone up whoa what the hell things got
kind of crooked follow the red dots Oh
down over there
captain's a little a bathroom is
upside-down hello dot no flashlight mmm
like I've said before I spot
hmm and now the hospital has likely all
gone the [ __ ] I get it what's the past
out tonight Maryland pills there's now
two pill bottles
take the pills man okay okay what do I
do oh okay can't see hello City
Oh
I don't know Locke seems to be jammed
it's not going to open I forgot
same team throw Swedish ah yeah this is
how you use a knife I'll be right back
what all right that's all the time I got
for this episode wow this really just
goes to show it's not about the graphics
it's about the gameplay it's about the
environment thank you guys so much for
watching he'll be enjoying so thanks
again for watching and as always see you
bye bye